- I'm scared for you to have my phone.
- Who do you think I am? Like-
- I know who you are.
(laughter)
(soft jazz music)
- She's married and I'm single.
I think Jake's gonna know.
Don't you think?
- He might.
- I mean, you guys text regularly, or not?
- Yeah.
- Like, what do you guys text each other?
(laughter)
- I don't know.
- I'm a straight girl.
Taylor is a lesbian.
- Probably get some,
like, messages on Hinge
and Tinder and Bumble.
- I can't think of a better friend
than a friend who helps you get laid.
(record scratches)
- What?
- Oh, it's on.
- No, I'm not ready.
(hysterical mumbling)
- I just have to delete a couple texts.
- Oh, my God.
(soft jazz music)
- Oh, man. I'm gonna change your life.
- I'm gonna change your life.
- We are on hour one.
- I've already matched with three ladies.
- I think 99% of the texts
have had some sort of emoji,
and that is making
people believe I'm Sarah.
- I've probably told her
husband that I love him
about five times today.
- Jenny is officially
trying to ruin my life.
I just got on my Facebook on my laptop.
Jenny checked in at a gas station.
"Thinking of growing my hat collection."
(soft jazz music)
The only solution here is
to fight fire with fire.
(woosh)
- While I was at the gym,
Taylor went a little overboard.
(record scratches)
You asked my Facebook friends
for anti-diarrhea medication.
How is that okay?
- Her own husband does not know.
- No one caught on.
- There's probably gonna
be a lot of messages
on Hinge and Bumble, a
little bit of Tinder.
- I am so efficient that
last night I had a dude
ready to come over immediately.
"You're pretty fine *eggplant*"
- My goal was to get Jake to
ask Morgan out on a nice date.
- Oh, I like that goal.
- I didn't accomplish my goal.
(laughter)
- Oh, dang it.
- I found some good matches for you,
and I hope you keep talking to them, so
- Thank you.
- You're welcome. I
hope you continue that.
I'm unmatching everyone
you matched me with.
(soft music)
- I wouldn't do it again.
- No, we would not do this again.
- I guess we both care, like,
what people think about
us a little too much.
- Yeah
- I don't want this ever again.
(kiss)
- Did you really set me up on a date?
- Yes. 100%
- I see. You have seriously-
- Drinks on Saturday night.
- It's a double date, though.
- It's a double date.
- That's so awkward.
- I know.
- Do you even go on double dates?